esta imagen no volverá a repetirse
pronto Luego de que el gobierno talibán
revocará el acceso de las mujeres a las
universidades este miércoles cientos de
estudiantes fueron rechazadas en las
puertas de las instituciones en lo que
significa otro revés para los derechos
de las mujeres en Afganistán
cuando me acerqué a la universidad de un
ambiente extraño los vehículos talibanes
estaban estacionados en la puerta de
entrada y los talibanes estaban
comportando tan mal diciéndonos regresen
a sus casas las niñas ya no tienen
derecho a estudiar esta situación tiene
un impacto muy malo en todas las
estudiantes
[Aplausos]
la prohibición desató protestas de
estudiantes en las puertas de las
instituciones de educación superior en
repudio a la medida
todo el enfoque de los talibanes está en
cómo reprimir a las mujeres no quieren
que participemos en el desarrollo del
país ni que trabajemos al lado de
nuestros hermanos solo quieren que las
mujeres se queden en casa y den a luz
Eso es todo
los islamistas de línea dura aumentaron
las restricciones en este año de
administración expulsando a las mujeres
de la vida pública y coartando sus
derechos a la educación la mayoría de
las niñas no pueden asistir a clases más
allá de primaria pese a las promesas del
gobierno